what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to re be reacting to
these signs that your relationship won't
last long with esther
perel and louis i've seen this
relationship coach
all over social media she seems really
interesting i'm excited to
see what she has to say before i start
do not forget to subscribe
to the channel as you guys know my goal
is 20 000 subscribers each and every one
of you helps
while you're at it ring that
notification bell for
daily videos okay let's start this
what are the core reasons or the core
things you see over and over that
either end or make a relationship
challenging to be in
the longer end what are the what are the
ones that what are the challenges that
come up over and over that you see
there's always three questions right
what's a driving relationship
a thriving one yeah what can go wrong
and how do you fix it okay so you
started with the middle question
what goes wrong
i think there's a number of things in a
relationship that that uh
that become just the kind of
cornerstones of the demise okay and i'm
not going to lease them in order but
they all
are part of each other um
indifference and contempt
and neglect and violence are probably
the four
most important okay i'm not talking
about big violence microaggressions are
plenty
indifference when you start to feel like
the other person fundamentally is not
really caring about you anymore or you
don't care about them
what they feel what they think who they
are what they're about
don't care you've lost interest but it's
more than losing of interest it's also
when you are doing different you degrade
the other person they're less important
to you they don't
matter and ultimately what we feel in
relationships
is that we matter that is the essential
reason for connecting to people is that
oh my gosh that's so true i've never
thought about it like that but she
vocalized something that like everyone
wants to feel in a relationship
we are creatures of meaning right i
matter to you i'm someone
you care about me you want my male you
want my well-being
you're proud of me you you want good for
me
you're benevolent all of that when you
are indifferent the
whole thing goes and then you start to
this that coldness that creeps in that
sense of estrangement that complete
disconnect
that the second one is neglect neglect
when people just basically take each
other for granted
you know they take more care of their
car than of their partner
their dog anybody anything their yard
anything
anything gets attended their business
for sure
their business for sure you know i
wonder if that's why you see so many
super successful
people that have been married like two
three times
because they literally don't have time
for a reason everything gets priority
everything gets
reviewed evaluated attended to
360s you name it you know new input
my god it's like people have this idea
that they put it all
in when they were dating and then once
they sealed the knot
it's like as if they tied the knot it's
like now they don't have to do squat
anymore and they go into this kind of
complete sense of complacency and
laziness
it's an amazing thing they think this
thing is just going to live on its own
right like a cactus right violence
violence the abuse the level of of
disrespect i mean
most people talk nicer to anybody else
than their partner when a relationship
because you can't get away with it
because you can't get away with it
because if you talk like this at work
you're gone
oh my goodness i have never
thought about that it's not even just
with like
your romantic partner but i think of
like my family
right like i hate i hate to say this but
like
you know my mom like she'll talk
completely everyone knows everyone's mom
you know they'll
talk completely different to like other
people than like at the house
because if you talk like this with the
police you're gone because if you talk
like this on the street you're being
punched
but with your partner you have that
sense that they're gonna be there anyway
they're just gonna take it
because it's family and family is this
kind of
this thing that doesn't dissolve so
easily so
you can just lash out at them and talk
to them with a tone
and a dismissal that is phenomenal so
that kind of violence i'm not talking
physical violence and all the other big
big things you're talking about
aggression or resentment or
all of that yeah all of that you know
passive aggressiveness all those things
yeah all of that
and then and then um contempt i think is
the top one
contempt is the killer of them all
because in
in the contempt there is a real there's
the degradation of the race
is that that complete this you're
nothing you're nothing
i can kill you with that one guess that
one eyebrow that goes up
you know stuff do you who do you think
you are what are
and that's it you you're done you're
done so how do we even get to this place
of these
these places after having been so in
love and so romantic right
is desire uh reflect that or if we're
not desiring the person anymore then we
start to feel one of those categories
or does that not play into look the
truth is this
there's only two relationships that
resemble each other
the one you have with your parents or
the people who raise you
and the one you have with the people you
fall in love with
people can sit in my office all the time
and say i have this with no one else
i don't have this with anybody at work
nobody among my friends ever thinks like
that you're the only one who speaks like
this or thinks this about me or with
whom i do
no you're the the only one and now we go
back in history
and i'm sorry to be the psychologist but
that's really
it is the place where we often learned
about
closeness trust loyalty commitment
sharing taking receiving asking
all these essential verbs of
relationships we learned that at home
we also learned jealousy and
possessiveness vengeance
you name them the beauty and the not
beauty yeah we saw it all as children
right we saw the fights we saw the love
we saw the you know we saw the coldness
the lack of intimacy the intimacy yes
and we bring that with us and we often
promise ourselves i'll never be this one
i'll never be this way i'll never talk
like this i'll
you know and we find ourselves often
much
closer i find that it's not really anger
and in relationships that really ruin it
or where the issues come from
from my experience and just like
watching other people it's frustration
it's like not knowing how to solve
something
and then presenting ourselves to the
tree we resent ourselves we're like how
did we do that well why don't we get to
this place
and then we feel ashamed about it and
since we don't like to feel ashamed
about it
we hide it and one of the way we hide it
is we blame the partner
that's just one of the ways we are very
resourceful in not owning our [ __ ]
right exactly exactly wow okay
um and where does sex play in all this
and desire
so i mean the one of the fascinating
things for me
in looking at sexuality is that it's
probably
one of the dimensions of relationship
that has changed the most
in a very very short amount of time for
most of history
and it's still the majority of the world
sex is for procreation
sex is a marital duty on the part of the
woman nobody cares particularly
if she likes it and how she feels and if
she wants it
and um and men have the privilege to go
and find sex elsewhere
in a very short amount of time we're
talking 60 years
we have contraception which is the
liberation
of women for the first time to free sex
from reproduction from mortality
from and that's so
interesting to me how women have like
chosen like the decisions that women
have made when they're given the option
to decide
because a lot of the manosphere content
is saying that
the feminist and like adoption of birth
control all that stuff
has been like bad for women but really
you're giving women
like the option to be like 100
themselves and like do what they want to
do
but what i would say is that before
birth control it really saved women from
themselves and like the negative sides
of women
death in pregnancy and in childbirth
sorry all of that
and for the first time sexuality moves
from just biology and a condition
to a part of our identity and a
lifestyle in 60 years
in 60 years the women's movement which
goes
after the abuses of power the gay
movement
which introduces the concept of identity
to sexuality
the fact that sex is for connection and
pleasure the fact that for the first
time we have sex
before marriage and many times a lot we
used to marry
and have sex for the first time now we
marry and we stop having sex with others
okay monogamy used to be one person for
life
now monogamy is one person at a time and
people go around telling you i'm
monogamous in all my relationships
and it makes perfect sense to me okay
all of that in a very short amount of
time the fact that i choose you to marry
or to live together doesn't matter
commitment
because i'm attracted to you because you
give me butterflies in my stomach
and the fact that i think that if i
don't have these butterflies anymore
maybe i don't love you anymore
and the fact that sexuality in long-term
relationships
is rooted in wanting only desire i feel
like it
i want to not i have to not we want many
kids
after two kids the only reason to
continue doing it with you is because we
feel like it's right it's pleasurable we
connect
it feels good it runs our relationship
the whole thing
that's it and hopefully it's at the same
time and for each other
because plenty of desire continues but
it's not always at home
right exactly so this is an amazing
revolution
sex that's confusing all of us and how
do we sustain it so that's why i became
fascinated in
the nature of erotic desire and how do
we sustain desire because it is the
first time
ever that we have a grand experiment of
the humankind where we want
sex with one person in the long haul
that is fun
and connected and intimate and playful
and we live twice as long go figure
right exactly
for 60 years you're going to be with it
or whatever it is yeah it's an amazing
idea so how do we navigate this if we're
going to choose one partner
and be with them until you know we're
both gone how do we navigate the
challenge of
keeping the desire continuously
i think both men and women because the
woman probably sees other men who are
attracted to her
and you know vice versa so it's like how
do both parties do this
look we know that women get bored with
monogamy much sooner than men
wow really two factors that's research
really i i'm shocked
by that because isn't there studies that
say women have like better sex and
long-term relationships
i'm sure but she probably knows what
she's talking about so i'm gonna just
listen
that's not just fact that's uh that is
men's desire in long-term relationship
goes down gradually
he actually is much more able to remain
interested and
maybe just because he's interested in
the experience itself and he has a
partner there
women's desire post-marriage wow
and it's always been translated as well
that's because women care less about sex
rather than it's because women care less
about the sex that they can have
in their committed relationships which
is often not interesting enough for them
and it often has to do with the fact
that the story the character the plot is
not
in it's not seductive the romance which
is an essential ingredient of turn on
for the woman
yeah because women want in my opinion my
humble opinion
women want to be seduced like every
single time they have sex where
men like just want to do it whenever
they don't care
often disappears in the long-term
relationship it's like do
people look at each other at the end of
the day and you want to fool around
you want to do it you're up yeah yeah
this is really
this is not very much of a turn-on for
most women
and the idea that foreplay often starts
at the end of the previous orgasm
you know and not five minutes before the
real thing which for her
is not the real thing the whole the real
thing is everything else
so it's essentially yeah yes like
like women are turned down by the way
you treat yourself it's creating a game
seduction
it's a plot it's a coming close it's a
team history
it's what animals call pacing it's that
i come to you but i don't overwhelm you
i come just a little bit so that you can
come a little bit toward me and then i
don't immediately answer i actually go
back a little bit too
have you ever seen animals they do this
kind of pacing
and it is an essential playful
ingredient
of seduction and excitement
so women's desire plummets but
we interpret it as women are less
interested in sex
rather than women are interested in
probably just about the same kind of
things that many men are
but women have always known what to
choose above what turns them on which
was what gives them stability and
security
security family right someone to protect
be there right
so what people do look this is we
want one partner today to give us
everything that involves stability and
security and everything that
involves playfulness and mystery okay
that's the grand ideal
okay i want to be cozy with you and i
want to have an edge and i want you to
surprise me and i want you to be
familiar and i want you to give me
continuity and i want you to give me
novelty
that's it as if it's uh right and no
victoria's secret is going to solve that
yeah right so then it becomes what is
desire desire is
to own the wanting if you ask people a
question that goes like this
i turn myself off when i turn myself off
by
not you turn me off when and what turns
me off is
you're going to hear i turn myself off
when i do emails
when i spend too much time on the phone
when i over eat when i don't
exercise over eat oh my gosh
bad days at work when you ever eat like
a ton of food
and you're just like oh my gosh i don't
feel confident
when i numb myself when i feel dead when
i don't feel contriving when i'm not
alive
you will really hear that it has very
little to do with sex
and when you ask people i turn myself on
when
or by i awaken my desires
not you turn me on when and what turns
me on
is which is i you're responsible for my
wanting right what people will talk to
you about is when i'm in nature
when i'm connected with my friends when
i get to do my sports
when i play music when i listen to music
it's through stuff that gives me
pleasure and joy
a life that is vibrant that is vital
that is
erotic in the full sense of the word as
a life force
and from that place people remain
interested in having sex with somebody
else for the long haul
not because they've yeah and that's how
why it's so important to be doing
something you actually like doing
because and i i had this realization
because i was in a sales job that i
hated i literally hated it
and i thought i would like it because i
heard sales is like terrible at first
but
everyone told me like if you just give
it a year give it this amount of time
you'll like it but i've been a year and
a half and i was like this is literally
the worst time i've ever had
and um and so i had to like
write down a list of things that i liked
that i like genuinely just enjoyed doing
because and the way that and it's
actually harder than you would think to
figure out what you
actually like enjoy doing like a lot of
people don't know and the way i figured
it out
was i was like i'm gonna write down
everything that i would do
even if like no one would do it with me
because i'm really extroverted like i'll
do anything if someone else likes to do
it
but i was like what will i do if i'm
living by myself alone i'll do it by
myself
wrote down that list and that's how i
figured out youtube because i literally
can research and like watch stuff for
hours
but what the point i'm making is i
realized like
that i just was not happy living
in a way where i hated my life scratch
their arms for two seconds right
it's i feel good about myself
the biggest turn on is confidence right
confidence you ask people when do you
find yourself most drawn to your partner
every description has to do with when
they're in their element
stage when they're with when when when
they're doing their sport
when they when they are radiant when
they are
yeah on the piano on the horse you name
it it's when they are in their
element i.e they don't need me to take
care of them
they're not depressed and down and
lonely and sad
they're not needy they don't need me
because desire is about
wanting you love is also about needing
you
wow caretaking is a this lady is so
wise she's so very powerful experiencing
love
and it is a very powerful
anti-aphrodisiac so how do you
experience love and desire at the same
time you
calibrate it so sometimes you're it's
the same as when you walk
you have to move from one foot to the
other a balance
is not about staying on one side a
balance is the ability to see
right now we don't need caretaking we
can be mischievous we can be naughty we
can be playful we can break our own
rules we can stay home and not go to
work at eight o'clock
right and now we are in a playful zone
now we are feeling that we are bringing
our own little transgressions home
we are alive we're not just being
dutiful responsible
good citizens right it's that it's very
small
yeah you know i mean i always think when
i go
and i see people at lunch and you see
them talking and they're well dressed
and they're awake and
i think who is here with their partner
because you can see them they're engaged
they're giving the best of themselves
that's erotic
no the majority are not there with their
partner they're there with their friends
with their colleagues their partner is
going to get the leftover when they come
home at night
sorry you know what forget the night
date meet at lunch
when you actually have energy you know
when you
and in the middle of the day like that
when you're awake when you have
something to offer
it's a very small thing but they don't
they don't do it and you say why not
why not why don't you stay an hour extra
at home in the morning and not just
because when you have a headache
and just say this matters to me all in
all you know committed sex
is premeditated sex it's not just gonna
happen
because whatever is gonna just happen
already has so
you're gonna make it happen because you
say we matter
we're important let's do this let's
spend doesn't mean if you're going to
make love or have so it just means
we're going to take this hour and
there's nothing else that matters in
this moment but just you and i
to be together to check in and then
we'll see what unfolds
that's the erotic space in which sex may
happen
probably will doesn't have to but it is
the place from which it is much more
likely to emerge
but people don't do that they do the
responsibility
that's the love right the citizen the
commitment the caretaking the burdens
the safe
and then they say i'm bored
i would be too okay exactly there's no
mystery there's no risk taking right
exactly yeah
there's no risk-taking that's the word
if you want desire
it's risk and the risk is an emotional
risk it's not about sexy risks
it's really a risk on the emotional
front is that
i bring something else to you today
differently from
um differently from from the way i
typically present myself
sure you know how can i do this
something
what can i do today that will be
different from the ways that i've done
it until now
how can i do something that i think
would actually improve our relationship
me right not something that i want or
that you want but that i think would be
actually good for us that third entity
the us
right and you check every time you know
how often do you just go on the tried
and trodden
as in you know it works sex that just
works
for most people is really not
interesting enough right so
because what does it mean it works
generally right
what about people listening or saying
man that sounds like a lot of work that
every day you have to change
do something different and unique and be
not every day not every day
not every day but what you can do every
day
is just a quick check with yourself you
know is there something that i should
notice is there something that i can be
thankful for
is there a little note that i could
write is there
you know just a way that i can show up
at time it's small
it's really small and that's the thing
about relationships
is i think it's spell oh shoot i think
especially men
don't and maybe women probably don't
either
like how much the little things just
like mean
to your partner like just like the
smallest like tiniest
details mean um here's the thing
there is work and then there is the
creative work
you know i'm talking about a level that
is creative and that elevates you and
that actually
gives you you feel you feel taller
you just feel like you're engaged you
feel awake rather than
this this is the other seated position
it's comfortable it's great but nothing
happens here
sure this this is alert
here's the essential word is curiosity
when you're curious you lean forward and
you watch
you're open to the mysteries of life
this is please don't bother me with
anything because i don't want any
stimulation i've had
my share i've been you know and this is
the position that most people have at
home
so when people say it's too much work
um i basically say look
you you if i was to say this in your
business
would you say this is too much work oh
that's such a
she's stating facts this woman is so
wise
oh you would say that's very good advice
this is high rate consulting fees
it's like excuse me but you don't think
for a minute that your business would
thrive
if you let it languish like that
never you have a reward system you have
incentives
bonuses bonuses but there is no
incentivized system as in the in the
private domain
so people just think why bother right
and that's the difference is that the
ones who have good relationships are the
ones who created their own internal
incentive
incentivized system what are some of
those incentive systems that you've seen
over time that really work
or effective for long-term relationships
i would say the first thing is almost
one of the first things that our parents
teach you
please and thank you do you know how
many
people stop how many people have said
that
you should watch how they treat a waiter
thanking
their partners thank you thank you for
doing this for me to thank you for
picking up the shirts thank you for
you know making you feel appreciated yes
appreciation
appreciation is huge gratitude
acknowledgement of the presence of the
other in your life
not did you do this did you call
did you pick up do this you know half
the time
expectations expectations of course you
know expectations is often a resentment
in the make
uh it's like with the expectation comes
the fear of it's not gonna
tank person first of all and because it
also makes it feel like
this is not a given nobody owes you
squat
you're not owed anything you're not that
important you're actually quite
replaceable
right and with the divorce rate that we
have
um what's the rate at right now 50 on
first and 65 on seconds
it's not good right it's really you know
it costs a lot of money
it's not good for the health i mean it's
just like you know it's not good for the
jobs it's
it's just it's like okay now you could
say maybe people should marry but
it doesn't matter if it's marriage
legally or the idea is that
we can do better we can do better in
general i really think that the quality
of our lives depends on the quality of
our relationships i mean nobody's gonna
write
you know uh you
worked some 60 70 80 90 hours a week and
you know no they're going to say he was
there for people when they needed to
he was there at every game he was there
at the party he's the guy who
when you were in his presence he had
charisma
not because he could stand in front of a
huge crowd but he had charisma because
when i was in his presence he made me
feel special
it's a different charisma so
appreciation
gratitude thank you um little things to
go out of your way
rather than just to do the minimum a lot
of people start to do the bare minimum
just so that they can't be scalded right
go an extra thing
um on occasion just do something for the
other person just because it matters to
them even if you couldn't care less
right rather than i don't it's not
important to me i don't
i don't need this or i don't care about
this yeah i think that's really
important
give each other a lot of individual
space not everything needs to be shared
people have different passions different
interests different friends
and they need those separate spaces to
exist
and it gives you something to talk about
and then if you do everything together
admiration i think is huge um because
admiration is also that you kind of
really see the otherness of the other
person
um don't try to make your partner into
one person for everything
there is no such a person find multiple
sources
of connection of intimacy of friendship
so that you can
have a group of people support you and
don't have one person
who has to be there for you for
everything especially when you're in the
dumpster
we used to have a village of people to
do that now we just expect one person to
be the villager yes yes yes
one wow that's really that's really good
advice
like you can't expect to put everything
under person for the whole village
that that is that is a unique it is and
and then we're upset when they don't
fulfill the mandate
and that's the more import like i can't
talk to you you're not supportive of me
you're not excited for me excuse me find
other people
right you know i can't be everything for
you no exactly no
and if you want to learn more wow that
was
sorry if i didn't talk enough i was
honestly just like listening that was so
interesting i think that was her name
esther
brings a level of wisdom that you really
don't see from a ton of people let me
know
in the comments what you agreed with
what you disagreed with personally
i thought i really don't even have any
disagreements she was right on the money
do not forget to subscribe